hello and welcome back to Playstation
grenade we are going back to hitman two
this time we are in Colombia taking down
the three headed serpent three of the
world's biggest drug cartel leaders in
the same place at the same time so let's
murder them all
let them Hunter Huss begin Oh sir you
trying to reach that blunt you can do it
you can do it you're so close let me
give you a hand still Livingstone excuse
me he's back hit so hard oh well he's
swimming with the fishes now welcome to
Colombia heya joined the boy band we are
the new I need to think of some boy band
names we are the new Backstreet Boys
favela boys no wrong country
backstreet's back alright right let's we
have synth we have guitar we have it's
grippy thing and I'm on the drums let's
do this boys rock and roll
[Music]
to the music
[Music]
come on beeps come on sing with us and
dance with us in the streets of Columbia
we're going to stay all day you drop a
statue on a man's head are the people
with us tentative eat just wait 10
minutes for the guy to come across from
the streets rush of massive statue on
his head then run away if they say
anything few minutes later how come my
cravat doesn't match your province feel
like I've been targeted because because
of my lack of hair do you think I should
tell him that I've conquered with that
statue drum roll nope
I refuse I will not give you a railroad
no I refuse okay my little bits good now
let's get the drum roll I was noise my
accession what would happen though if we
didn't actually do the drum roll an exit
reload try it all over again give you a
drumroll not a chance
[Music]
you piece of I don't even care about
that man dying I am with you how could
you do this to the band we're breaking
up we are breaking up the band is over
the bellboys have gone
but idea run away with your new best man
you got it ah come on so we'll I'll do
my best this is literally my first ever
tattoo but I believe what you do first
you draw on the person's neck but this
is the bit which makes you a level above
everyone else into slices throat or
something I wasn't expecting
inner ear action go on 47 so I'm a
drug-dealing
is this the guy from Sapienza the hippie
from Sapienza it could be from the first
season here
here's your school bus with lots of
drugs inside the best taste in drugs
I've ever made have fun oh you're not
feeling too good after those drugs hey
you you're running like I do you need
the toilet man Kubrick
oh the statics by Franco confirmed down
nice work 47 chief Diana duties
foreigners this is sparta not a place
for foreigners sorry about your friend
she's swimming with the fishes now go
with her be free be free from column B
on the cell Columbia welcomes foreigners
submarine what can we do with this we
can disable it that's boring what else
is there
oh so we can rev the engine up I say
I'll probably explode when it gets too
light low five or something where's the
guy anyway oh why you dude be ready to
get her one
yes she's ready I just need you to stand
near the front you really like y'all so
greens
[Music]
begone lovely working with you sir come
on have a nice day
I don't know love's I've got a letter
for you shut up scroll anywhere I don't
want anything from that bum well what
you want me to do with it it's a letter
for you where I'll put it in your entry
mmm and now we wait
do you like the letter she's reading it
she's reading the letter romantic fool I
had no idea you felt this way
Hector loves you do that he loves you so
much yes he's really changed
brothers oh my god that's a bad way to
go excellent work I'll keep the letter
I'll be in love with Hector instead me
and Hector were meant to be together
this this looks terrible I look
absolutely embarrassing anyway where do
we where do you need me to do my stuff
oh there's bones in there human human
remains what do you need me to do this
stage is all yours
Lyn's away i will cleanse this out of
this here we watch this for cleansing
clinton what sorry cleanse
yeah it's finished the site is clean now
is that the greatest thing you've ever
seen anyone know we need to drop it on
her head she's in position drop it away
Lizzy way man
I don't know what happened there
Martinez is down was nothing to do with
me it's in your can you let me in please
just one man with a knife and all
hello you're not gonna shoot me
Bella I'm gonna keep knocking on this
door Avon calling please could you come
out and buy something from my catalog
sir oh he doesn't look happy okay okay
he's going down nice to meet you I don't
run from a fight this is the next door
the gateway to hell come on let's let
the bodies
oh I love this AI this AI is on par with
my actual ability come on it's two-month
come on come at me bro
come at me dude
ah this is really therapeutic that's
murder
you're the come on dudes you're the last
one
you got this you gave me five you gonna
be fine um maybe now take a couple of
aspirin come back in the morning is that
the model how many do we know about 15 I
am the drummer of death Wow
there is a lot of people there next time
answer the door who I got a bowl hey yo
oh that's speed that's spike don't drink
yeah it doesn't matter I have a bone to
pick with you
consider yourself boned by agent 47
right I'll say what Jen's I'll fix this
machine nobody else seems to know their
ass from their elbow that was easy
I could easily be an engineer the
machine is looking
do you think we could push somebody in
this come by and have a look where is he
oh he's running he really wants to see
this machine I fixed you machine boss
are you proud of me Dad it's perfection
this will change everything everything
everything you're suddenly overcome joy
you're very welcome this is what happens
when focus is applied alongside proper
work ethics yes this is the future
people you listening Lance Pappas very
proud of me I fixed your machine that's
disgusting
right I will have my vengeance in this
life or the next
the love that went into that machine to
make it work but no no you're not
bothered you should be take care of your
workers and your workers we'll take care
of you like that
hey blood-stained cocaine brick that's
the way he wanted to go I'll miss you
papi come round here woman please you're
very revealing top I want to see if this
cement spreader works
go but ki Fateh been into the site is
clean now I I have become a master of
this scene I've played it so many times
thank you right let's get to the cement
spreader and be ready to hit her goodbye
my friend
hey you don't swim over a post sinking
there he is right let's get your boss
and throw him in back in a sec you're
beautiful bestir I am thank you happy
you know I think we need to cut down on
your protein for a while huh huh yes yes
we do juju you doing machine hi papi oh
is that it anything else to say what are
your last words must be more than you to
do what's your last words say something
oh that was something else
all targets neutralized this should
paralyze it's so damn good see you soon
what the hell have we found it's like
Tomb Raider or Indiana Jones we're gonna
die we're gonna die we're gonna die
we're gonna die this is gonna take hours
to figure out there must be a path
between all the steps I was 303 across
was it one more across no yes done we
have a sacrificial dagger was well worth
it I look like an idiot
look like a plonker anyway let's go back
to stabbing people holy Sh
okay I wasn't expecting confetti right
here he comes
we're gonna drop the chandelier on his
Swiss box it's gonna be insane it's
gonna be don't go up the stairs
Oh God's sake man right this time we
have the chandelier and I put a gun
underneath it so when he comes in this
time he'll see the gun walk over it and
pick it up and then I can drop it on his
head come on you get out the way guard
this is just for him all the way got
I wasn't for you goddamnit right let's
just just take things into our own our
own predicament we've got the tools to
fix this literally
toi bien all I want is was you to walk
underneath this bloody chandelier once
and did you do it
no I've wasted an hour of my life
therefore I will waste your entire life
is this this will be beautiful you will
be happy with your demise what the hell
is Mike there it is good night sweet
drips lovebirds
I like his sloping forehead he's got a 5
head it's not a forehead that's a 6 head
you know what you're both gonna die
together two lovebirds you are tina's is
down that's how she wanted to go open
the parcel bomb right further away this
time you won't hit me from here leave
late good work she's vanished she's in
the ether when you look I didn't do it
run away Hey
hello young lady
you should you really that's a good fire
but you should really be wearing more
clothes this is not the kind of place
you want to be dressed like that did you
just turn off my jacuzzi what you think
this is you'll say sorry to every single
one of those bubbles you're okay that's
not very ladylike is it just just move a
little bit for just
our bubbles from good
this is not going well Boston Crab yeah
Bostick do submit do you serve Brits say
uncle Bret the Hitman Hart here nice but
here we go sharpshooter sharpshooter
what do you say you look much better
this is coming grip the crossface
morosely
oh hey you got my blood in your face can
we escape on this GU tape this is how
it's done
see you Columbia it man forever big so
there we have it
a thousand ways to complete the mission
here in Columbia I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade I'll see you next
week with another location and another
way to take down everyone it's been a
pleasure
see you next time